بملاييننا وملياراتنا
نظمنا وبصوت واحد عشرات الآلاف
من الأشخاص خرجوا إلى
شوارع لندن مطالبين بوقف إطلاق النار في
إسرائيل، وتوقف حرب حماس، ووقف إطلاق النار الآن،
وسيبدأ شهر مارس الآن في
وسط لندن، لكن الوجهة النهائية
هي سفارة الولايات المتحدة.  في جنوب
لندن، وهذا هو المفتاح هنا،
الغضب الذي نسمعه هو في الغالب
غضب مباشر تجاه الحكومات الغربية،
وخاصة الولايات المتحدة لدعمها
لإسرائيل،
وقد شهد الصراع الذي دخل الآن شهره الثاني غزة تحت
القصف الإسرائيلي المتواصل في  أسابيع منذ أن
شنت حماس هجومها على إسرائيل في 7 أكتوبر/تشرين الأول
في شهر واحد، هناك أكثر من 4000
طفل يموتون، وهذا ليس طبيعيا، وبينما كان
الناس يستعدون لمسيرة تضامنية
مع الفلسطينيين، كان آخرون يحتفلون
بحرب تاريخية ثانية [موسيقى]
للبقاء على موعد إحياء ذكرى
النهاية الفعلية للحرب العالمية الأولى، كانت بمثابة
تقاطع وصفه البعض بأنه غير حساس،
حاول رئيس الوزراء البريطاني ريشي سوناك في البداية منع
التجمع المؤيد للفلسطينيين من المضي قدمًا،
ومن المفترض أن يكون يوم آرموس حول نهاية
الحرب وهذا هو بالضبط ما
يفعله الناس  نحن هنا لأننا نريد أن نرى نهاية للحرب
في غزة وهذا ما
نؤيده، وقد وعدنا بوجود مكثف للشرطة
في لندن يوم السبت، وقد
واجهوا تحديات من قبل
متظاهرين من اليمين المتطرف
قاموا بتعطيل الصمت لمدة دقيقتين على
الهدنة  قبل يوم من الاشتباك مع
الشرطة في وسط لندن، تقول الشرطة إنها
اعتقلت العشرات من هؤلاء
المتظاهرين المعارضين في أعقاب مشاجرات
للمتظاهرين المؤيدين للفلسطينيين الذين تجمعوا
خارج السفارة الأمريكية في نهاية
شهر مارس، وبدأت مشاعرهم
تظهر أنني أريد فقط أن أقول إنني يهودي و  أنا
أؤيد تمامًا شهر مارس وكل ما
يحدث اليوم، لماذا لا يمكننا جميعًا
الوقوف إلى جانب
الفلسطينيين، لذا على الرغم من الجدل
والفترة التي سبقت هذا الحدث، فقد
ظل منظمًا للغاية وسلميًا إلى حد ما،
لكن حجمه يعكس ما نحن عليه بشكل
متزايد  رؤية هذا المزاج العام المتنامي
أنه على الرغم من الهجمات المروعة
التي وقعت في 7 أكتوبر، فإن الرد ربما يكون قد
ذهب بعيدًا جدًا. سي. سيباستيان سي إن إن لندن